Today, many of the best examples of innovation in business...
...or in education or in society or government...
...are coming from young people who are using the web.
This is a powerful tool to change the model.
So, this is a whole new mode of production that's emerging.
The Internet is not about putting a video onto YouTube...
...or creating a gardening community online or having a cool website or a government portal.
This is a new mode of production that's emerging.
It's beginning to fundamentally change the way that we orchestrate capability in society...
...to innovate, to create goods and services, to govern, to educate.
That's the meaning of the web.